jennifer and jeffrey so wonderful to see
you i watched the film last night and
i can't believe this was released at
sundas in
2018 and this time it couldn't be
perfect
to have this film out at the current
time so
who or what is the monster
great question that that is the question
i think that the film raises um
and you're right uh you know we made
this film i guess
five years ago now i think um and you
know there's a little bit of frustration
that it hasn't
come out to this point but as you say
um it it's really well timed it's a
story for
these days and it's the story um that i
think will resonate in really positive
ways
um and uh and and be a part of a
conversation that needs to be had
this question of who the monster is is
one that is raised within the film
um there's a lot of ambiguity in the
film it doesn't answer
questions uh it doesn't it doesn't
make judgments of guilt or innocence
even even though uh you know we go
through this trial process but in some
ways there's still
lingering questions and i think it's for
the audience then to answer those
questions to answer
uh the question of where the monster
lives does the monster
live within an individual does it live
within a system
uh is it non-existent is it just a
boogeyman
um so um
i won't answer that i'll let the
audience answer them
jennifer i mean the fact that you're a
mom and to play
a role like this have you had that hard
conversation with your son
it's i had to mention that we were
watching
one of his tv shows that he likes to
watch and it was an episode about
some young black boys trying to get into
their own home
and the police came up and they were
only about his age
11 and they said get on your knees you
know
and the other kid was like get on your
knees and i stopped and i looked at my
son and i said what would you do
in that scenario because as a black
mother with a black son
i have to have those conversations and
that's why i do
think monster is so well timed because
it's so necessary
for today and there's so many lessons in
the film to me it's a
a great film of different perspectives
you know and which i feel is so needed
today
for us all to be able to get past
all the craziness of this time is when
we can stop
and look at life from each other's
perspective and i feel like the
the perfect way to do that is through
art
is through storytelling which is what
master is doing
it is a brilliant film so one of the
things i want to know is how do you guys
relax how do you just keep that spirit
alive in yourself and keep that energy
positive in yourself
i do press junkets
when i'm not doing that i i try to get
in the ocean i try to surf
uh as much as i can i haven't been able
to do that
as much lately as i need to but that's
uh you know that's my
my uh my peaceful place you know
and gently um
i don't know what i mean i love
music so even when i'm not working doing
music
i'm still doing it when i'm at home
whether it's listening to it
um learning music singing long as i'm
around music i'm happy
congratulations to both of you thank you
for this film really
thank you